so i have some data here in a
spreadsheet you could use microsoft
excel or you could use google
spreadsheets and we're going to use the
spreadsheet to quickly calculate some
parameters let's say this is the
population let's say this is we're
looking at a population of students and
we want to calculate some parameters and
this is their ages and we want to
calculate some parameters on that
and so first i'm going to calculate it
using the spreadsheet and then we're
going to think about how those
parameters change as we do things to the
data if we were to shift the data up or
down or if we were to multiply all the
points by some value what does that do
to the actual parameters so the first
parameter i'm going to calculate is the
mean then i'm going to calculate the
standard
deviation then i want to calculate the
median and then i want to calculate
let's say the interquartile range
enter
i'll call it i
q
r
so let's do this let's first look at the
measures of central tendency so the mean
the function on most spreadsheets is the
average function and then i could use my
mouse and select all of these or i could
press shift with my arrow button and
select all of those
okay that's the mean of that data now
let's think about what happens if i take
all of that data and if i were to add a
fixed amount to it so if i took all the
data and if i were to add 5 to it so an
easy way to do that in the spreadsheet
is you select that
you add 5
and then i can scroll down and notice
for every data point i had before i now
have five more than that so this is my
new data set which i'm calling data plus
five and let's see what the mean of that
is
so the mean of that notice is exactly
five more and the same would have been
true if i added or subtracted any number
it the mean would change by the amount
that i add or subtract and so and that
shouldn't surprise you because when
you're calculating the mean you're
adding all the numbers up and you're
dividing by the numbers you have and so
if all the numbers are 5 more you're
going to add 5 in this case how many
numbers are there 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 12. you're going to add 12 more 5's
and then you're going to divide by 12
and so it makes sense that your mean
goes up by 5.
well think about how the mean changes if
you multiply
so if you take your data and if i were
to multiply it times five what happens
so this equals
this
times five
so
now all the data points are five times
more
now what happens to my mean
notice my mean is now 5 times as much so
the measures of central tendency if i
add or subtract well i'm going to add or
subtract the mean by that amount and if
i scale it up by 5 or if i scaled it
down by five well my mean would scale up
or down by that same amount and if you
numerically looked at how you calculate
a mean it would make sense that this is
happening mathematically
now i mean look at let's look at the
other measure the other typical measure
of central tendency and that is the
median to see if that has the same
properties so let's calculate the median
here
so once again you want to order these
numbers and just find the middle number
which isn't too hard but a computer can
do it awfully fast so that's the median
for that data set what do you think the
median is going to be if you take all
the data plus five
well the middle number
if you ordered all of these numbers and
made them all five more the orders you
could think of as being the same order
but now the one in the middle is going
to be five more so this should be 10.5
and yes it is indeed 10.5 and what would
happen if you multiply everything by 5
well once again you still have the same
ordering
and so it should just multiply that by
5.
yep the middle number is now going to be
five times larger so both of these
measures of central tendency if you
shift all the data points or if you
scale them up you're going to similarly
shift or scale up these measures of
central tendency
now let's think about these measures of
spread see if that's the same with these
measures of spread
so standard deviation
so
stdev i'm going to take the population
standard deviation i'm assuming that
this is my entire population
so
let me
why is it
so let me make sure i'm doing so
standard deviation
of
all of this
is going to be
2.99 let's see what happens when i shift
everything by 5. actually pause the
video what do you think is going to
happen this is a measure of spread so if
you shift i'll tell you what i think if
i shift everything by the same amount
the mean shifts but the distance of
everything from the mean should not
change so the standard deviation should
not change i don't think in this example
and indeed it does not change so if we
shift the data sets in this case we
shifted it up by five or if we shifted
it down by one your measure of spread in
this case standard deviation should not
change or at least the standard
deviation measure of spread does not
change but if we scale it well i think
it should change because you can imagine
a very simple data set the things that
were a certain amount of distance from
the mean are now going to be five times
further from the mean so i think this
actually should we should multiply by
five here and it does look like that is
the case if i multiply this by five so
scaling the data set we'll scale
the standard deviation in a similar way
what about interquartile range whereas
essentially we're taking the third
quartile and subtracting from that the
first quartile to figure out what kind
of the range of the middle 50 percent
and so let's do that we can have the
quartile function equals
quartile
and then we want to look at our data
and we want the third quartile
so that's going to calculate the third
quartile
minus
quartile
same data set
so now we want to select it again
it's the same data set but we this is
not going to be the first quartile so
this is going to give us our
interquartile range this is the
calculates the third quartile on that
data set and this calculates the first
quartile on that data set and we get
2.75 now let's think about what the
interquar whether the interquartile
range should change and i don't think it
will because remember everything shifts
and even though the first quartile is
going to be five more but the third
quartile is going to be five more as
well so the difference shouldn't change
and indeed look the distance does not
change or the difference does not change
but similarly if we scale everything up
if we were to scale up the first
quartile and the third quartile by five
well then their difference should scale
up by five and we see that right over
there so the big takeaway here and i
just use the example of shifting up by
five and scaling up by five but you
could subtract by any number and you
could divide by a number as well
your
the typical measures of central tendency
mean and median they both shift and
scale as you shift and scale the data
but your met your typical measures of
spread standard deviation and
interquartile range
they don't change if you shift the data
but they do change and they scale as you
scale the data